valoriser les innovations aéronautique
compatible avec les engagements
écologiques et environnementaux pris par
le gouvernement notamment lors de la cop
c'était l'objectif du secrétaire d'état
des transports en visite à toussus le
noble
il a lui même essayé cet avion
électrique alpha électro plus propre et
surtout moins bruyant destinés à la
formation des pilotes en service depuis
presque un an
nous avons un avion qui vole et le fait
que le ministre vienne
c'est un facteur supplémentaire pour
faire comprendre à l'ensemble des
parties prenantes que oui on est sur une
solution de transition énergétique avec
un avion volant avec de l'énergie
électrique
la visite s'est poursuivie avec la
présentation de la start-up turbo tech
qui présente son avancement dans la
construction de moteurs propres
l'entreprise une dizaine de salariés
vise une centaine d'embauchés à
l'horizon 2025 dans l'aéronautique ya
beaucoup de concurrence surtout dans les
nouvelles technologies dans la
propulsion électrique turbo tech
actuellement une longueur d'avancé donc
la france a une longueur d'avancé qu'on
aimerait c'est allé très vite pour
pouvoir justement garder sept longueurs
d'avancé et des premiers à proposer des
solutions réellement utilisable de
propulsion hybride pour l'aéronautique
ce qui est le cas actuellement
et c'est donc au travers des discussions
que j'ai eues ici la conviction que nous
serons inventé en france un modèle qui
réconciliera à la fois l'écologie
l'industrie les territoires et le
progrès ce qui dans les temps que nous
connaissons actuellement me paraissent
tout à fait à propos des avions dont la
pollution environnementale et sonores
sont diminués des innovations
développées à toussus le noble dont
l'objectif est donc aussi de rayonner à
l'international